Sunday school teacher by day and a sex
addict ignite.
Ooh.
They were like,
you won't believe it.
We got her going out.
We got her with the men and we get to
show her and she was willing to show us
everything.
I sat down with a woman for the
interview that was taped and during the
process of the interview I said,
why are you doing this?
And she said,
oh,
I want to help people.
I want to tell my story and I want to
help people.
I said,
do you have children?
She says,
yes,
I have a 10 year old son.
I knew right then this is never going to
see the light of day.
So we got off the air and I said to the
lady,
we are not going to air that show.
And she said,
why?
My producer said,
why she knew she was being filmed.
She knew what she was saying.
She knows what I said because her son
will never get over it.
You always know it's the right thing.
When in the end there was peace.
You are rewarded by peace in knowing
that you did the right thing.
The three things that I want to leave
with you will carry you if you let them,
first and foremost,
knowing who you are,
being able to answer this question,
who am I and what do I want so I'm not
asking for the roles that you play as a
daughter,
as a friend,
as a sister.
You're going to be a lawyer.
You're going to teach,
you're going to be a pharmacist.
I'm asking the bigger question of who am
I and what do I want?
I don't want to just be successful in
the world.
I want to fulfill the highest,
truest expression of myself as a human
being.
I want to fulfill the promise that the
creator dreamed when he dreamed the
cells that made me.
You must have some kind of vision for
your life.
Even if you don't know the plan.
You have to have a direction in which
you choose to go.
You want to be in the driver's seat of
your own life because if you're not,
life will drive you.
Number two,
you must find a way to serve.
Martin Luther King said that not
everybody can be famous,
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service.
When you shift the of whatever it is you
choose to do to service and you bring
significance to that,
success will I promise you,
follow you.
That's number two.
Number three,
it's so simple,
but so hard to do.
Always do the right thing.